mélanie bonjourbonjour approché vite que
je vous dise un secret à l'oreille j'ai
décidé de faire de la concurrence à
julie sur le chapitre de l'élégance
vous avez vu mon nouveau chapeau qu'il
est vous n'est ce pas
ce travail médiante épuisé où je vais
m'allonger derrière ce dossier en
attendant
ce que j'ai ce n'est
pas mon
eau la jolie corbeille de fruits
or ça c'est une très bonne idée de
mélanger les fleurs et les fruits bon si
cette corbeille et là je suppose que
c'est pour que l'on s'en serve un bien
je vais commencer par grignoter ses
jolies petites cerises
délicieuse
je vais recracher les noyaux
voilà je mets les noyaux dans la
corbeille car il ne faut pas salir le
jardin ce qui fit rôle à la luxueuse
devraient être ouverts depuis longtemps
mais monsieur quel désordre
casimir tu es là qu'est ce que tu as
acheté 20 n'ont rien rien du tout rien
mais pousse toi fois où les jolies
marguerite je vais en cueillir quelques
vip pour décorer mon casque un bond aux
savanes faire est booké
splendide dis moi tu connais le jeu qui
consiste à effeuiller les marguerites
non pas du tout attends je vais te
montrer
j'aime l'île aux enfants un peu beaucoup
passionnément à la folie pas du tout
enfin c'est pas gentil il sera temps ça
n'est pas fini un peu beaucoup
passionnément à la folie pas du tout
c'est un drôle de jeu oui mais ce qui
est beaucoup moins drôle c'est que j'ai
mon kiosque arranger je n'aime pas ça du
tout tout à l'heure bien
julie mais enfin oui il ne faut pas
jeter la tige des fleurs par terre oh
mais tu as raison casimir attend il faut
laisser le jardin propre je vais
l'acheter dans la corbeille comme ça
bien ça sera parfait à tout à l'heure
j'apprécie de plus en plus votre
conversation me savait tellement de gens
est gens restent cois bouche bée est
maqué gravi émerveillé au jour j'aurais
pu dire si ce sommet est vrai mais les
ouï dire que je n'ai pas trouvé un seul
mot dit remarquer j'apprécie toujours ce
que vous racontez ça j'avoue que
quelquefois je ne comprends pas très
bien enfin je sens que c'est beau à je
ne vous le fais pas dire mon cher emile
les grandioses ses hôtes là et les
données tenez savez vous à quoi ça me
fait penser à non mais ça me fait penser
un bon repas aussi je crains bien ça
tombe bien
regarder ce casimir cache derrière son
dos qu'est ce que c'est oui mais ils
sont à moi je laissais vu le premier
engagé pire tu ne voudrais pas partager
avec nous partager bon bah toute façon
je crois que j'ai pas tellement le choix
boas les bombes et les mouches 2000
vous annonce après coup mon bon maître
bon très bien alors je vais prendre
cette pomme et bien moi cette foire
[Musique]
qui
alors juteuse et cette foire du pur jus
de fruits
je vois est juteuse ne verra quasiment
rien à quoi y'a pas de quoi réjouir
je remettais trognon et
[Musique]
bon
ils ont tous mangé les goinfres
ainsi plus qu'à l'aller
quelle chaleur aujourd'hui
ça on peut dire que le soleil tape fort
ça alors un vieux chapeau de taille
petite formidable il va me protéger du
soleil
aulaqi vad
mais c'est françois
nouvelle fuite
mais enfin françois vous n'avez pas
envie de profiter de mon sommeil pour
essayer de me voler mon chapeau mais il
aimait demoiselle futé je ne fais pas
deviner que vous étiez sous ce chef
mais enfin je vous promets encore jamais
je me serais permis de faire faire une
chose pareille ça vous me connaissez
mais bravo à ces châteaux va ravir
formidable au petit matin mais non mais
non mais non eh bien je veux y avoue
part d'un mai mais à une condition et à
lantier laquelle bien que vous demandiez
à tous les enfants de venir faire un jeu
sur la décoration de mont joli chapeau
jeu sur la dgos bon si vous voulez les
enfants venez venez vite venez vite
mademoiselle fit et a besoin de vous
elle voudrait savoir ce qu'il ya sur son
chapeau parce que c'est ça notre
union
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
et qu'est ce que c'est que ça
et ça
merci les enfants mais
enfin mais qu'est ce qu'il raconte
c'est une bulle
[Rires]
n'est ce pas qu'il est bon ça
[Musique]